we were warned to the elderly in our
society would be amongst the most
vulnerable to the spread of coronavirus
even so we can now reveal allegations
the high number of deaths in care homes
may have been exacerbated by the
government's own policies over the
transfer of Kovac patients from
hospitals Sky News has spoken to dozens
of care homes about the guidelines
fearful of repercussions none would
appear on camera
in a statement voiced by an actor this
is what one owner said to us my anguish
and sadness is purely arisen from the
thoughtless and neglectful conduct of
the local authorities the morning that
providers admit into their homes co vid
positive and untested residents this has
undoubtedly caused a huge spike in the
infections and resulting in deaths that
were avoidable thousands of deaths have
now been recorded in UK care homes with
the help of care northeast and the
registered nursing homes Association we
contacted a large cross-section of care
homes in Britain more than 90 responded
to us we asked did you feel pressure
from hospitals to take patients 70% told
us they did we asked did hospitals
discharge patients to your care home
with Co bid 19 symptoms before April the
15th 41 percent said yes and we asked do
you think kovat 19 positive patients
discharged from hospital caused the
virus to spread in your care home 38%
said yes they did at the start of the
outbreak I revealed concerns about the
impact the policy would have this was
the original advice the government gave
to care homes negative tests are not
required prior to transfers admissions
into the care home by mid April they'd
been a change of policy the guidelines
then said we can now confirm will move
to institute a policy of testing all
residents prior to admission to care
homes this will begin with all those
being discharged from hospital
but by then some care homes say the
damage was done
Keith gray represents 250 care homes in
the northeast of England I believe it
was one of them the major factors that
caused the outbreaks and the care homes
but there is we could probably never
prove this but we believe it was one of
the major factors do you think that
policy cost lives cost the lives of the
elderly in some care homes in this
country I don't believe it probably was
a factor
we can't ever be for certain but I
believe it was a factor yes Sky News has
obtained these letters sent by a number
of local authorities exposing the
pressure put on care homes to comply
with the original Kovach guidelines
several councils said they would
withhold so-called uplift payments extra
money to deal with the outbreak unless
the homes agreed to new terms including
taking in confirmed kovat patients and
it wasn't just councils pushing care
homes to take kovat patients Digby Manor
in Birmingham prides itself on its
stringent safety measures and its Cova
'dry status its owner says saying no
meant going into battle with the NHS a
fight which he claims in spite of the
policy change hasn't gone away the
Department of Health and Social Care
said it's untrue that government policy
has allowed the spread of coronavirus in
care homes and that they've been working
with the care sector to ensure they've
had the best advice based on the latest
scientific evidence the Prime Minister
has described the situation in care
homes as an awful epidemic that has to
be reversed the strategy to protect the
NHS has so far worked but some care
homes feel it was a policy
failed to shield their elderly residents
Lisa Holland Sky News Birmingham